hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Scarlet Witch video as
promised
obviously the movies gonna change a few
things about what's going on with
Scarlet Witch in the comics so I'm gonna
do a comic-book explainer and then I'll
explain you know what the movie is
changing about the character mostly just
the backstory she's like one of those
characters in the comics that has God
level powers at certain points so I
think Joss Whedon whatever version he
decided to go with deep Howard her just
like a little bit to make it a little
more believable compared to the other
characters just to get things started
let's do origin story so Scarlet Witch
and her brother Quicksilver were created
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby as they did
many other characters in 1964 she
appeared for the first time in x-men
number four in that issue the the
classic x-men team goes up against
Magneto and the Brotherhood of mutants
for the first time Scarlet Witch and her
brother are just part of that evil team
but at that time they were not Magneto's
children that didn't get added to their
backstory till way way later in Avengers
186 in 1979 so many many years later you
could thank John Byrne for making the
Magneto's children in that issue Bova
tells Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
there their story of their mother Magda
he's like your mother came to me she was
pregnant she gave birth to twins Magda
was the wife of magneto so thus they
became Magneto's children fast forward
all the way to today during the the axis
event that happened last year and they
kind of retcon that so they said Marvel
said officially they're not gonna
explain Scarlet Witch and quicksilver's
knew back story in the comics until they
start the new uncanny x-men title after
Secret Wars so if you are a big comic
book fan you'll probably have to wait
till after Secret Wars to find out what
their new back story is in the comics if
you don't don't worry about it it
doesn't matter just watch the movie the
movie will totally explain what's going
on with them the reason Joss Whedon and
Marvel had to change their backstory for
the movie it is really kind of silly
it's just because in the comics they
bounce back and forth between x-men and
Avengers so much like they appeared in
the Avengers for so long that Marvel and
Fox share rights so they can both use
versions of those characters it's just
there are a few things that they can't
do for instance Marvel cannot use the
word mutant that is something that Fox
owns as part of its x-men copyright
that's why Marvel is making such a big
deal the Inhumans like they want to do
metahuman powers people with special
abilities the Inhumans is
the way for them to do that it's just a
way to describe people with metahuman
powers and whenever the movie gets here
in May they'll spend like the first 15
minutes or so kind of explaining where a
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch come from
it'll be way easier to follow but let's
do a comic-book history cuz the Scarlet
Witch is one of the most interesting
characters so for the most part scarlet
witch's biggest moments have been when
she's been part of the Avengers most of
you have probably heard about how she
had a relationship with the vision and
then they had two children that turned
out to be magic babies that were fake
that ended up happening way way later
she first joined the Avengers in 1965 in
issue number 16 in a story called the
old order changes Stanley just wanted to
change the lineup I think he felt like
some of the Avengers were getting boring
so he wanted to bring new characters in
so he replaced Thor Iron Man giant man
in the wasp with Scarlet Witch
Quicksilver and Hawkeye if you guys have
been following the news they've said yes
they will be changing the movie version
of The Avengers they'll be changing that
roster in the next couple years just
bringing in some fresh meat for the
Infinity gem grinder in the comics
though whenever Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver first joined up they called
the new squad caps kooky quartet I mean
even those technically still the
Avengers but look for an Easter Egg for
that in Avengers age of Ultron cap
spooky quartet so one of her next big
you know really weird storylines was
starting the romance with the vision
that didn't start till 1973 an issue
number 109 that's also the same issue
where Hawkeye bailed on the Avengers he
left as weird as it sounds starting a
romance with a robot they kind of
addressed that Quicksilver her brother
at the time was like this is bullcrap I
can't believe it Hawkeye really hated
the idea too but he was just jealous he
was in love with Scarlet Witch too so
here's where things start to get a
little weird she envisioned leave the
Avengers in issue number 211 they have
like a 12 issue limited series where
it's like Scarlet Witch in the vision
it's all about their relationship later
she winds up getting pregnant with the
vision using magic remember he's an
Android
can't father biological children even
though he's probably fully functional
like data from Star Trek she gives birth
to twins Thomas and William if that was
volume 2 issue number 12 that was around
like 1986 then they end up joining West
Coast Avengers so the next big art kind
of leads up into Avengers disassembled
where she goes completely nuts
so slowly like her world starts to get
torn down around her the vision gets
dismantled in a big fight and wonder man
whose brain was used to like patterned
visions brain won't allow himself to be
used again to make a new vision so she
can't get her husband back and then she
loses her children
you can thank John Byrne for all this
this is like 1980s John Byrne era so in
1989 West Coast Avengers issue 52 it's
revealed that her twin sons are actually
soul shards from the demon Mephisto in
order to defeat him they have to erase
scarlet witch's memory then eventually
she remembers what happened and she kind
of starts to go a little nuts much much
later her powers start to get upgraded
she starts to get her chaos magic she
wants to get her children back like she
wants to use magic to bring them back so
she goes to dr. doom and he helps her
fuse with this cosmic entity which
upgrades her to like God level power
this is like the beginning of the House
of M event probably one of the most
famous Scarlet Witch storylines of all
time when she merged with that cosmic
entity it takes over her mind and she
goes a little nuts and starts a war
against the Avengers she just she blames
them for all the bad things that have
happened to her and her family
eventually they're able to stop her in
magneto Quicksilver like her family take
her away to recover because of the
damage that she had caused Quicksilver
freaks out and is worried that the x-men
and the Avengers are gonna try to kill
her so he convinces her to use her Chaos
magic to create a world where everyone
gets everything that they've always
wanted that's the really famous no more
mutants line right there
that happened in house of M number 7
much much later they're able to undo the
damage but they can't undo the stain on
Scarlet Witch like everyone looks at her
differently they're like okay you
completely messed the world up you are
totally crazy during x-men vs. Avengers
whenever they were fighting the Phoenix
force she and hope combined their powers
to say no more Phoenix in a nice twist
on the no more mutants line so that
repowered everyone and it kind of
reversed a lot of the damage that she
had done so as you can see she has like
crazy level powers and has had some
really ridiculous storylines movies
naturally probably ganna sidestep her
having magic babies with the vision but
I think they will have some more fun
with the idea of her chaos magic and her
and her powers just to explain her
powers they're pretty interesting one of
the reasons Joss Whedon said he wanted
to
put her in the movie is because her
powers work in a way that we haven't
seen on screen it's just like really new
and interesting also I think she just
she works the matically with the idea of
an Ultron vision based story Joss Whedon
said initially like his idea for
Avengers 2 was he wanted to do Ultron
and he wanted Paul Bettany to become the
vision in the movie like that was the
basis for age of Ultron and then he
built it out from there he wanted to
bring in some other new characters so I
think you know based on that foundation
Scarlet Witch just worked best just like
a lot of other characters you know over
her comic book history her powers have
evolved like they've gotten bigger and
bigger and bigger and then they've kind
of turned him down a little bit but as
of where we are right now she has like
cosmic level abilities which is I think
kind of works with the movies and the
infinity gems her biggest power is the
ability to manipulate probability over a
limited area so like inside a bubble she
can cast the hex that will give the
Avengers really good luck or four powers
backfire like if her hex backfires it'll
give him really bad luck you can see how
that'd be really useful in battle like
if a pile of Ultron replicants start to
bury the Avengers in a fight she can
cast a hex bubble making it easier for
them to win eventually she learned to
use that ability as a form of tactical
aneesa's so she can deflect objects open
doors make things explode create force
fields she can even make electronic
circuits go haywire so you can see that
would come in handy if she has to fight
in her army of robots later in the 1990s
she learned to use more traditional
magic like Doctor Doom and Doctor
Strange use there was even a run that
Geoff Johns wrote on where she was able
to resurrect Wonder Man I know everybody
thinks it's weird Geoff Johns has been
at DC Comics for so long but he did
write at Marvel before he came to DC
House of M though that was where she got
crazy universe altering powers obviously
for the movie they're gonna deep power
her a little like they're not gonna give
her two the ability to change the entire
universe but during the Avengers vs.
x-men run they explained that her magic
comes from a cosmic source cosmic like
the infinity gem and Loki's staff which
brings us to the movies so if you
remember at the end of Winter Soldier
they had that Baron von Strucker
post-credits scene where they talked
about experimenting on test subjects and
the survivors and it's like the twin
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver are the
only survivors of their experiments with
Loki's scepter Kevin Feige already
confirmed that the mind gem is in Loki's
staff they haven't full
explain the extent of its powers or its
effects on Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
so we'll have to wait for the movie to
figure that out but I think that they'll
explain her powers across the course of
the film like we'll see her use certain
powers at the beginning and then in then
later in like the third actual unveil
some mega super power it just feels like
a very movie thing to do like oh you
thought this is all I could do BAM here
we go infinity stone power as
predictable as big Hollywood movies are
I think there'll be a few surprises in
terms of her powers I mean it'll be
interesting to see a play out on screen
this picture of her mind controlling
Black Widow just looks so awesome
there's a lot of theories that that's
the reason why the Hulk is fighting Iron
Man because she like pew puts the whammy
on all them it just makes him go crazy
for all intents and purposes though
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch are the
beginning of special powers inside the
Marvel Cinematic Universe obviously they
have the Inhumans too and their powers
come from a different source but it's
all about seeing mutant abilities on
screen as opposed to like science-based
abilities like Thor with his hammer and
Iron Man with his suit really the next
step from here is explaining dr.
Strange's full-blown magic hopefully
we'll get a small tease of that and
Captain America Civil War because Doctor
Strange is like the next movie after
that here's my big question for you guys
what's your favorite Scarlet Witch story
of all time and do you think that she's
gonna have like some crazy moment in age
of Ultron where I should go like no more
mutants like a version of that where
she'll just destroy an army of robots
just on paper it seems like the visions
gonna be the one to help them defeat
Ultron but I am expecting a big Scarlet
Witch moment as much as the movies
change stuff from the comics they do try
to honor like the really big comic book
moments in related Inhumans news there's
gonna be new agents of shield next week
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video I've already done it an explainer
video for the Inhumans if you haven't
seen it you can click here to learn all
about them
and you can click here to learn all
about the new Supergirl TV series I'm
interested to see which direction they
take it in but I haven't seen the pilot
yet so thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight now let's all
do the thing
you